you've probably heard the phrase that
for every force there's an equal and
opposite reaction force and this is also
known as newton's third law of motion
but it's also one of the most
misunderstood laws of physics so that's
why we're going to dig into it a little
bit in this video
so i have two examples here where
newton's third law or this notion of an
action and a reaction force is happening
so over here you have this plane flying
and the plane is able to move forward
by pushing air particles through these
jet engines so these air particles are
pushed outward at a very very high
velocity out the back of the engines
if you were to enlarge one of those air
particles let's say this is this purple
dot right over here there is a force
that is being exerted on it by the jet
engine and that force is going in that
direction
so what is the equal and opposite
reaction force
well the equal and opposite reaction
force is not also occurring on that
molecule it's what the molecule is doing
to the plane
the equal and opposite reaction force is
that the molecule is going to be pushing
on the jet engine with an equal but an
opposite force so it's going to go in
the opposite direction and that's how
the jet is able to accelerate forward by
pushing on these particles and
accelerating them backward by exerting a
force on them the equal and opposite
force is the force that the particles
those molecules of air are exerting on
the jet and moving it forward
the same thing here is going on with
this rocket
you have some rocket fuel in there it
gets ignited it explodes and as it
explodes there's a force that exerts on
those little molecules and that force
is going in this direction
but as it does that there's an equal and
opposite force that the molecules are
exerting on the rocket the rocket is
having a force acted on it once again
equal and opposite
so it's important to realize that the
reaction force is not on the same object
it's on the other object if one object
is putting an action force on another
then the second object is putting a
reaction force on the first the forces
do not cancel out
it's also important to realize that both
forces are generated in pairs and happen
at the exact same time there's no delay
we can look at other examples of this
this is a scenario that i would never
want to be caught in being drifting
through space now this astronaut here
has some type of a rocket pack that
might help it move around but let's say
your rocket pack
ran out of fuel and you're just drifting
through space how can you get back to
your spaceship
well if you have a wrench or something
on you that you can throw
if you can
take that wrench
and if you can push that wrench in that
direction and let's say your spaceship
is over here to the left
well the equal and opposite force is the
force that the wrench is going to exert
on you the astronaut and then it will
push you in that direction and
accelerate you in that direction so
that's a useful thing if you ever get
caught drifting through space but you
can do an experiment right now
press on the table in front of you when
you press on that table you're clearly
putting a force onto that table if your
table is soft you will see it get
compressed but notice your finger itself
is also getting compressed and the whole
reason why you can even feel that is
because your finger is getting
compressed and that is the equal and
opposite force that the table is putting
on your finger and this can happen at
very very large distances as well
the whole reason why the moon is in
orbit around the earth is because
there's a gravitational force
of earth's mass acting on the moon but
there's an equal and opposite
force of the moon
acting
on earth
and it's actually not that the moon is
rotating around the earth it's actually
they're both rotating around the center
of mass of their combination that just
happens to be so much closer to earth
it's actually within earth's volume that
it looks like the moon is rotating
around the earth and this isn't just
celestial bodies i weigh 165 pounds that
is the force that earth is acting on me
due to gravity but it turns out that
there's an equal and opposite force of
165 pounds that i am pulling on earth
with
so i will leave you there look around
the world this is happening everywhere
for every force there's an equal and
opposite reaction force but they don't
cancel out because they're acting on
different bodies